hello I'm Ryan rental and I'm Jake
Gyllenhaal and we're doing a wired
autocomplete interview yes google your
own everyone has at some point in their
lives and you're like oh god feeling so
good about myself is that gonna go
is Ryan Reynolds Debbie Reynolds son Wow
incredible stories I would have to the
war stories
his Ryan Reynolds related to Ryan
Gosling Canada had sex with America and
then they made the two of them in their
twins yeah and both of them tried to eat
each other in the womb they didn't they
survived and because of the trauma they
both became actors there you go and
that's why the two of them are actors
and who they are I can't feel my life is
Ryan Reynolds missing a tooth what do
you know these are all my teeth what the
hell is going on missing a lot of games
let's get these calf implants out dude
while we're at it okay is Ryan Reynolds
oh look at you punch much a couple
hundred orphans and suddenly you're mean
I don't this is what I don't know
oh yeah give me now Oh God
my name's Jake Yoho this could just end
right now what is Jake Gyllenhaal who's
Jake Gyllenhaal you know what it is your
zodiac sign yeah you're a Capricorn
what does Jake Gyllenhaal's first movie
October sky no no it was a big movie
nope know what it was it a dangerous
woman maybe I think it was called your
parents that you'd be in a movie called
a dangerous woman yes
at what age I was like 11 there's a 10
there something was John Hall what does
he eat well she's funny you should ask
baby pandas what does Jake Gyllenhaal
tattoo say I don't have tattoos man what
time was Jake Gyllenhaal born I think
was born early in the morning I'm pretty
sure I was made early in the morning my
dad he doesn't pull out of anything
okay does Ryan Reynolds eat glass eat or
drink without swallowing is that your
final answer are you Steve Harvey in
this equation
I have tattoos wow that's interesting I
wonder all right next question
I got a few if you do that one let's
just do it
Wow yes I'm telling you right now I'm
sitting right next to him dude is
covered in eyeliner he's odd he has no
eyes you think lashes like he has no
eyes Razia snow eyes no eyes actually
only have one eye so the yes I'm sorry
No thank you for bringing up a really
horrible thing that happened to me does
Ryan Reynolds what Oh martial arts well
yes this fist right here for example
chilling - that's the creepiest review
ever better like like the hot butter
knife too hot that's the creepiest hair
I'm the Paul Anka of martial arts so
ready yeah does Ryan Reynolds am wear
glasses I do they're actually they're
totally fake those are just to make him
look super handsome ten vision I can see
right through you right now so I have a
twin brother Oh No incredible no no no
no I don't I ate my twin brother in the
womb
let's see what the next Jake Gyllenhaal
one is he's just not really that way
this one fast - no bad Jake Gyllenhaal
climb Everest yes
did Jake Gyllenhaal go to college I
didn't go to college yeah I did I went
to Columbia University oh yeah I know
that I come across as somebody who
probably is not that sharp figured he
was like at least an online University
did Jake Gyllenhaal do own stunts
generally I do unless it's like really
dangerous do you know who does my stunts
who Tom Cruise did Jake Gyllenhaal oh
here go Gigi do you know Maddie do you
know bad movie uh they're the Atlanta
band not have a band but the song it's
cool it's I don't why Ryan Reynolds got
a start you supposed to do this he paid
for it not sure why Ryan Reynolds wanted
to play Deadpool chocolates
yeah like every other guy I was
desperate yeah desperation definitely
like
elements of middle-aged panic you know
why Ryan Reynolds kissed Andrew Garfield
really is that really a question why I
know if you've seen end we're gonna seen
him and Andrew Garfield yeah I didn't
know I was kissing him until I found out
when I got home that night
there should be a map just to get out of
his eyes
yes they're like four hundred more cards
fire let's waste more life okay here we
go so ready Gyllenhaal say yes he can
and dance at nope can Jake Gyllenhaal
kiss dude I'm not Andrew Garfield sorry
by the way is Jake Gyllenhaal Andrew
Garfield the answer that is no how is
Jake Chuck how is Jake Gyllenhaal's a
great one that was Jake Gyllenhaal
pronounced hey - we've done it a
thousand times how to get Jake
Gyllenhaal's Rohan saw Hera do you know
scare that we have somebody just woke up
someone's taking your air very terrible
terrifying come on one more one more
this is so this is fun just one more
else we still see it what's one more
ready what does Ryan Reynolds phone
number seven six four five nine 37 40
that's my burner phone good job
okay what is Ryan Reynolds diet wigs
rocks sticks and a tiny bit of green tea
in my head get out of my head cause
motorcycle well it's a person built a
motorcycle that is propelled by my
question energetical is a person yes
he's Gary he said what this head longs
was Ryan Reynolds using indefinitely
maybe fake ones tossing out before the
Bluetooth ones and I thought they were
real so what does Ryan Reynolds use in
his hair
mostly just it mostly just swamp water
it's actually done exclusively with
politicians spit so that's how you get
this look hope that you learn more about
me today than you knew before
well I did I really did feel closer to
you yep